on
que représente ce chapeau
je vous dirais qu'il représente beaucoup
pour moi c'est un compagnon de tous les
jours
il est à la fois là est pas là c'est à
dire que quand je rentre de mon travail
tous les soirs et m'attend derrière la
porte
je rentre assez tard puisque je joue un
clochard dans mon jardin ou au théâtre
des nouveautés et il m'attend je sais
que je suis attendu par visons ça c'est
un bonheur pour moi il est à la fois
silencieux est un peu violent
aussi il est capricieux il est
indépendant il paraît que visons à
tourner dans un film
oui dans la farine viennent justement
parce qu'un ami terence est prouvé que
ce personnage austère avait besoin d'un
lien entre son côté disons le mot un peu
rébarbatif et le monde extérieur
pouvez vous nous raconter quelques
anecdotes concernant il est extrêmement
indépendant très gourmand quand il a
mangé chez moi il verra chili chez moi
c'est chez lui il est mon topo deuxième
état chez mes voisins qui sont des gens
absolument charmant qui ont aussi ainsi
à moi et il va manger leur le plat du
cir mois il ne se gêne pas et c'est
comme ça il est absolument sans gêne il
fait de repas ou quatre repas par jour
selon sa convenance
il n'aime le foie et le foie frais n'est
pas très gros nez enfin qu'il est
extrêmement gourmand oui comme nous
l'avons
et rapidement fermé auquel foule
sentimentale devise on a hélas savent
très bien que rien n'est parfait il a le
chic
le cheikh mais n'a pas de choc c'est à
dire que pour la vie sentimentale
là c'est un choix qui n'a pas de vie
sentimentale
il a aussi d'autres avantages c'est à
dire qu'il est au calme comme tous les
gens qui n'ont pas de vie sexuelle qui
laissait parfois et là je dois dire que
c'est très comique parce que sa voisine
la chatte duo est une chatte qui n'est
pas coupée et parfois il ya des débats
qui sont assez comique mais hélas n'a
pas il ne peut pas avoir de vie
sentimentale est ce que je me fais
comprendre oui
alice le repousse et en fête du travail
le repos pour moi c'est dans le travail
c'est comme vous voyez dans un cadre que
j'ai choisi avec cet animal que j'aime
oui il faut bien le dire que j'aime
particulièrement parce que il me donne
énormément de satisfaction je ne lâche
hervy pas d'être intelligent il est très
indépendant je ne m'embête pas il ment
pète pas et nous vivons en très bonne
compagnie
est-ce-qu'il pour connaître vous passez
sur le petit écran je ne ne peux pas
pour répondre à cette question mais de
temps en temps quand il y à des
émissions avec des animaux surtout des
oiseaux ils regardent avec énormément
d'attention
je me demande si une voix je ne sais pas
il m'a pas encore expliqué le problème
est ce qu'ils les cabotins près vous
voyez bien vous voyez bien comme ils et
cabotin il est il a d'ailleurs
l'habitude d'être photographié des
traits photographier les photographes
l'aiment beaucoup et il a d'ailleurs
tourné
avec moi excusez alors je ne peux pas
vous répondre en ce moment je suis en
train de travailler
j'aime beaucoup tous les animaux mais ce
que je n'aime pas c'est bêtifier avec
les animaux
ans
alice avoir un animal ou plusieurs cela
représente quoi court comme obligation
justement vous venez de dire ça
représente une obligation il faut
mériter les animaux il faut pas en avoir
en pagaille si on n'a pas le temps ni
les moyens
je suis absolument contre les gens
évidemment c'est un fait banal de dire
contre les gens qui martyrisent les
animaux mais surtout je n'aime pas du
tout du tout la chasse tué un animal
gratuitement c'est déjà c'est très
pénible quand il faut les tuer
ne serait ce que pour se nourrir mais
sortir de chez de chez soi pour avec un
fusil pour abattre des animaux je trouve
ça absolument lamentable pour un être
humain
vous avez encore des questions posées au
sujet de 10 ans merci